bem quem de nós não gostaria de saber
qual é o melhor caminho a tomar
nas nossas vidas imaginem se nós
pudéssemos ter um manual para isso que
ele nos traz esses episódios mais
significativos da vida humana
os nossos conflitos situações de medo de
dor de dúvidas a coisa certa a fazer e
nos ensinassem de uma maneira bastante
simples e precisa a como lidar com essas
situações
mas imaginem que tendo esse manual em
nossas mãos
nosso tratássemos de um modo desprezível
às vezes com descaso no máximo como um
objeto para entreter as nossas crianças
pois é exatamente isso que acontece
quando nós falamos em contos de fadas
contos de fadas no entanto são guias
para que nós encontremos o caminho a
tomar em nossas vidas
é verdade que muitas pessoas utilizam os
contos de fadas para muitos objetivos
diferentes e podem ser utilizados apenas
acredito que nós não devemos esquecer
desse grande objetivo dessa grande
finalidade que têm os contas apontar o
caminho das nossas vidas
acontece que os contos de fadas nos
falam através de uma linguagem simbólica
e essa linguagem o tempo acabou se
tornando uma espécie de linguagem
esquecida por nós mas não é lá tão
difícil assim pelo menos em minas gerais
por exemplo se nós falamos esse homem
parece uma tartaruga isso diz algo mas
se nós falamos esse homem é uma
tartaruga
nós não estamos com isso chamando esse
homem de animal fazendo um xingamento
ele
estamos obviamente nos referindo ao fato
de esse homem ser muito lento muito
vagaroso
nós falamos
jovem ela é uma lebre para correr
estamos nos referindo ao fato de ela ser
muito ágil muito rápida muito velozes
agora o que isso tem a ver com contos de
fadas já que falamos que contos de fadas
são guias para que encontremos o caminho
a tomar as nossas vidas
acontece que os contos de fadas são
histórias especiais que tem tudo a ver
com essa linguagem simbólica e tendo
esquecido
foi como se nós tivéssemos perdido as
chaves para esse baú de pérolas
preciosas que são os contos contos de
fadas no entanto são histórias especiais
mas não sei se vocês já pararam para
pensar nisso mas contos de fadas pelo
menos a maioria deles não falou
absolutamente nada sobre fadas
observem se nós falamos por exemplo
desse outro conto chamado de três
porquinhos
é um conto em que esses personagens vão
vivendo sua vida no cotidiano até o
momento em que começam a ser perseguidos
por um ovo um ovo malvado um outro
também bastante interessante chamado de
rapunzel conta a história de uma jovem
moça que acaba se tornando a escrava de
uma feiticeira de uma bruxa e um outro
que é uma história estarrecedora conta a
história de um homem horripilante cujas
esposas todas sumiam logo após se casar
com ele
na história chamada de barba azul
o que esses contos têm em comum já que
de fadas até agora eles não falaram nada
todos esses contos têm em comum o fato
de que eles falam sobre nós sobre cada
um de nós e o caminho a tomar em nossas
vidas mas até agora não resolvemos um
problema porque afinal de contas se não
falam nada sobre fado se chama um conto
de fadas
sempre se soube que a verdadeira vida do
ser humano é a vida que existe dentro
dele
nós a vida dos nossos imensos potenciais
e uma vez que o ser humano comece a
conseguir ter acesso a seus potenciais
ele se torna incrível e pode realizar
coisas incríveis
na antiguidade se dizia que esse rei no
interior do ser humano poderia ser
chamado de o belo reino
o reino das fadas dado o encantamento
que ele gera quando nós chegamos lá por
isso nós temos aqui um grande
ensinamento o mais importante quando nós
vemos um conto não é o que ocorre na
história
o fundamental é sempre aquilo que
acontece dentro de nós
observe quando nós falamos dessa
história que são os três porquinhos eles
viviam
o seu dia a dia com tranqüilidade como
nós que vivemos aqui assistir uma
palestra do texas numa boa e tudo
caminhava tranquilamente até o momento
em que um lobo malvado começa a
persegui-los ameaçá los
o que essa história está nos ensinando
até aqui que no momento em que você
decidir escolher e viver a vida que você
escolheu essa vida sofrera ameaças e se
você quiser de fato vivê-la você
precisará proteger lã e é exatamente
isso que fazem os nossos queridos três
porquinhos quando se põe rapidamente
construir as suas casas
um dá um jeito mais rápido constrói uma
cabana de palha um outro um pouco mais
esforçado constrói uma casinha de
madeira e um outro mais dedicado resolve
construir uma casa de tijolos
evidentemente como muitos de vocês sabem
quando lobo faz o seu ataque
somente a casa de tijolos permanece de
pé que essa história está nos dizendo
até aqui que se nós quisermos viver uma
vida de valor e preservá la
nós teremos que torná la sólida
construí-la consolida
nós devemos fortalecer aquilo em que nós
acreditamos são grandes ensinamentos
desses contos sejam as nossas casas
sejam os nossos desejos sejam as nossas
vontades mais profundo dos nossos
maiores sonhos você precisará se
esforçar para solidificar aquilo que
você ama
senão a história nos mostra que acontece
os lobos da vida e irão soprar e
derrubar aquilo que você mais ama são
grandes ensinamentos porque conto de
fadas eu gostaria que vocês lembrassem
são guias para que nós encontremos o
caminho a tomar nas nossas vidas entre
agora na história dessa linda jovem
chamada rapunzel
ela foi entregue por sua mãe para quitar
uma dívida com uma feiticeira que
situação
essa bruxa aprisiona rapunzel no alto de
uma torre não tem nenhuma porta só uma
pequena janela no alto da torre
rapunzel ficou tanto tempo lá que deixou
crescer os seus lindos e longos cabelos
a bruxa usava esses cabelos fazendo
tranças neves como escadas e subia para
fiscalizar como estava a sua prisioneira
mais tarde essa história nós vamos
perceber que também um princípio de
salvador sob por essas mesmas tranças
dos longos cabelos de rapunzel ea
resgata salva e essa história está nos
ensinando
vejamos por trás da história que se em
algum momento nós encontrarmos nas
nossas vidas em uma situação sem saída
deveremos deixar crescer as nossas
longas tranças de esperança não corte as
suas esperanças está nos ensinando
rapunzel não cortando seus longos
cabelos e vejam nessa história acontece
muitas coisas interessantes e mais o que
permitiria a esperança permaneça nos em
sinal
nós não costumamos pensar no dia-a-dia
esperar quando você não vê saída de
causar a dor é duro esperar quando você
não enxerga por onde ir
mas se você souber resistir se souber
suportar essa dor como suportou rapunzel
a esperança te trará uma solução são
grandes ensinamentos
vejam agora essa outra história como
falei completamente intrigante
estarrecedora a história de barba azul
ela também começa com uma jovem singelo
que vivia mais um dia no seu cotidiano
dos grandes contos muitas vezes começam
assim uma vida tranquila e ela depois de
muitos e muitos dias de festa acaba
percebendo que não é lá uma escolha tão
complicado assim se casar com aquele
sujeito chamado de barba azul e aqui nós
temos um primeiro ensinamento
quando nós nos distraímos nossas vidas
podemos ser levados a fazer escolhas
perigosas
e é exatamente isso que acontece com
essa jovem ela se casa com barba azul e
barba azul é um homem riquíssimo de
muitas posses dono de casas lindas
verdadeiras mansões e é pra uma delas
que leva sua jovem esposa para morar
quando chegam lá ele apresenta mansão
ela é enorme tem infinitos cômodos com
todo tipo de pirataria de jóias as
coisas mais lindas que vocês puderem
imaginar tinha nessa mansão e barba azul
precisa fazer uma viagem uma viagem de
negócios é um homem importante e ele
puxa um molho de chaves no bolso e
entrega para sua jovem esposa e diz a
ela que ela pode desfrutar de todos os
cômodos da linda mansão e de tudo o que
há dentro deles todos todos os quartos
estão à disposição dela pode entrar em
todos eles - em 11 500 pot-limit omaha
ela deve adentrar mas você sabe como
somos nós seres humanos
barba azul faz a sua viagem a jovem
esposa oferece uma linda festa na sua
riquíssima mansão chama suas irmãs suas
amigas convidados em geral
a festa está maravilhosa mas lá pelo
meio da festa não consegue mais suportar
esse desejo de entrar no quarto proibida
então o que ela faz discretamente se
afasta das convidadas e se aproxima da
porta e abri o que ela vê lá dentro
todas literalmente todas as esposas de
barba azul mortas e ali ela contempla a
sua sina o seu destino cruel vazou
retorna percebe a tradição percebe a
traição da sua esposa e diz prepare se
você vai juntar se a elas os irmãos da
jovem donzela ainda bem chegam a tempo
com suas espadas cavaleiros que são
matam barbazul ela herda a mansão e tudo
o que há nela que história que está nos
ensinando essa história está nos dizendo
que nós podemos viajar para todos os
cantos dessa terra podemos conhecer os
lugares mais maravilhosas
assim como a jovem esposa de barba azul
podia transitar por todos os cômodos
daquela imensa nação
mas se nós não pudermos entrar nesse
quarto proibido mas um quarto
maravilhoso que existe dentro de nós e
encontrar seus profundos segredos a
nossa vida será sempre sem graça
a imagem das esposas mortas de barba
azul é exatamente a imagem simbólica do
sonho
que nós focamos por não realizá-los
não as realizamos porque nós muitas
vezes permitimos que se barba azul que
existe dentro de nós
fale mais alto essas vozes de medos de
dúvidas que aos poucos vão sufocando os
nossos sonhos mas se nós pudermos e
soubermos superar essas vozes se
soubermos vencer barba azul e daremos
não só bens materiais mas o potencial
completo da vida que nós temos a viver
como vocês podem observar contos de
fadas não são simples histórias são
guias para o caminho a tomar as nossas
vidas não a origem definida para os
contos de fadas
desde as mais antigas civilizações
sempre desde que o ser humano existe
existem misteriosamente contos de fadas
eles trazem consigo um simbolismo
precioso aquilo que o grande
psicanalista que alguns haviam me chamou
de arquétipos os grandes modelos
psicológicos da humanidade
são verdades profundas não sobre mim e
sobre vocês sobre vocês sobre todos nós
é verdade que sempre foram são e
continuarão sempre sendo as mesmas
verdades
vejam que interessante em um mundo
marcado por essa característica em que
tudo muda cada vez com mais velocidade
nós temos nos contos de fadas essas
singelas histórias verdades que jamais
se alteram
por isso eu acredito que da próxima vez
que você tiver em casa assistindo às
notícias do dia preocupados com o futuro
concentrados e as suas crianças chamarem
vocês interromperem vocês chamarem para
compartilhar com elas e ler um conto de
fadas
eu acredito sinceramente que depois de
hoje
vocês viram no mínimo dar a elas um
pouquinho mais de atenção
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]